we want to be very thoughtful of what
we're doing because you're only as
vulnerable as the one person you let
down right and so I don't think there's
a lot of people in the game that
understand where the business world is
going and boy what you do for a living
you know you know at the position that
you're doing it at like it's just
hardcore you know what up vlog location
location location location just like I'm
sitting here right now and this Sydney
Australia Airport and the way I've been
thinking about business down here is
whether it's the modeling or surfing or
or footy kind of culture when you
understand the framework that you're
playing in you have a much better chance
of succeeding in this this little chat I
had with a first-round pick of New York
Mets I was really trying to articulate
to him and his family but really him if
you watch it carefully even though I'm
not directly addressing him that you
need to squeeze your moment I'm yelling
at all of you for squeezing this
Facebook Ads Instagram influencers
movement the way I didn't as much as I
wanted to with Google back in 2002
because it's a moment in time if you're
an athlete
and you're lucky enough to be drafted in
New York [ __ ] City you need to
[ __ ] work and whether you're drafted
in New York LA or San Francisco or if
it's a Dallas Green Bay or Detroit you
need to be smart about the unique
opportunities within the marketplace the
framework of this conversation is take
advantage of their surroundings if
you're going to UCLA or USC this year
take advantage of that environment it's
going to Duke or North Carolina
understand and take advantage of that if
you're going to travel through Europe
understand the rule you're playing in
and the advantages the fruits that you
could pick from you'll see that in this
interview well thanks for reaching out
and I've been looking forward to getting
together yeah
what I've seen because we're doing thank
you so I've seen the ground up thank you
again
sure speak to my son a little bit about
it and if you feel about so you know
given the opportunity that we're all
sitting here together let me I'm
thrilled to like do you want us given
that you have the most context obviously
your most context on your son this and
you've been able to context on me what
can I bring you the most value of is
this a theoretical conversation is there
some details underneath like I'm you
know to be very honest you know as you
know what we said with baseball versus
football and things of that nature like
I'm obsessed with the notion of paying
forward I think karma is the most
practical thing in the world even your
first email caught my attention from the
vibe the second one like coffee all that
stuff so it's all good vibes so family
that way like what you know would look
you know feel at the highest levels you
know I've been in two businesses my life
you know my dad had a liquor store so
I've been in the liquor and wine
business and now I'm in the advertising
Madison Avenue industry you know along
with my dad and along with my brother
we've been able to build much bigger
businesses quicker than anybody has in
both those spaces and they had one
common theme which was when I I think
what I'm good at is like cat scanning
the industry and when I looked at him I
was like wow this is what they're doing
wrong I'm gonna do this this being
probably our third venture Baner sports
I've never looked at an industry and I'm
because I'm an investor in uber and
Facebook and Twitter and all these
things I look at a lot of businesses not
just - I've run I've never looked at a
business more broken now I'm empathetic
to the agents to be very honest I don't
think it's a great business you know
making small percentages having nobody
really locked up you can have a kid for
a long time
you know you get fired before the real
money comes in like it's not a great
business and I think when a business is
not great it leads to bad behavior at
the same token I don't think AJ and I
necessarily in it to become rich and so
that allows us to be a little more
altruistic and to be very frank what I'm
most interested in which is to [ __ ] it
up a little bit they just don't care I
mean very basically you just they don't
care about their kids and honestly I get
that it's business but that's the
vulnerability we're the reasonably being
so thoughtful and listen there's a real
you know it's a real player it is a real
situation like and we've had some other
real situations in the NBA and things
that nature is we want to be very
thoughtful of what we're doing because
you're only as vulnerable as the one
person you let down right and so I don't
think there's a lot of people in the
game that understand where the business
world is going and boy what you do for a
living you know you know at the position
that you're doing it at like it's just
hardcore right you look it just did it
for me it's data right when you're the
human like you people think they're
going to the Hall of Fame as they should
how the [ __ ] do you think they got there
in the first place when you look at the
data the outcomes of careers you're you
know you're whole I'm sure you got you
guys know better than I do you're
holding your breath you're thinking
about this you're thinking about that
it's hardcore so there's some good
advantages in baseball with guarantee
contracts and there's if you can get to
that place but for me the biggest thing
is you have to strike and squeak when
you win the outcome of like this great
thing has this low of percentages you
have to squeeze the [ __ ] out of it while
you've got the leverage and so so you
know I take a I tell a lot of I'm a duck
I'm a big Jets fan I tell these kids
when they're a jet I'm like look you're
in New York City
like I'm meaning with you you think I
would meet with you if you weren't in
New York if you weren't number 32 I
would never spend five you know and
these kids don't I think add extra
McDougall I think right I think about
all these kids like while you're in the
when you're the dump when you're a draft
pick of that team like the amount of
people that are like ruling the world
especially in New York that are diehard
Met fans that really give a [ __ ] right
now and may not listen I'm an old-time
baseball card collector Brian Taylor was
the first pick overall the New York
Yankees and we all cared
did you grow up a Yankee bib I love it I
love it I get it I get it yeah I get it
but it's still great that he's sitting
there that's better uh but right Brian
Taylor forget about the contract he got
which is probably why we all knew who he
was because there's a big one at the
time you know every CEO and this is the
biggest is the biggest city in the world
call what it is cared about you know 1/3
above that that's right and so for me
the most important thing like if I was
part of this team an enormous amount
that first of all I think the other
thing that's gonna allow us to be
successful in the thing you should be
always thinking about is does the person
representing you have empathy and when I
why I think about empathy so much in
this business is my strategy would be
like hey my man we need to meet
everybody who gives a [ __ ] about the
Mets that matters in New York that can
put you on whether that's advice whether
that's getting you business
opportunities whether that's writing you
a $50,000 check when you're probably
worth $1,500 as a face of the marketing
campaign because they can afford it and
they love the [ __ ] Mets
let's do that on the flip side the
reason I said empathy is if he's like
man I just need I'm just working on this
third pitch like I don't like being
around people I don't want to go do this
I don't want people up in my you've got
to have empathy so I think for us
uniquely because of the marketing
machine we definitely have to be smart
and listen carefully of like who says
they want that who needs that
and that's why the agents are vulnerable
these agents the CAA said they've got
six moves and you've got to fit into
their moves they're gonna try to get you
a sneaker deal they're gonna try you
know they got six moves and so what
we're trying to do is create a Swiss
Army knife instead of a hammer and then
to be very frank win on the only thing
you can win on the which is if he quit
tomorrow because he fell in love with
yoga retreats and that is his calling in
life be his homie for that too and I
think that's why we're gonna win
ultimately because if you're in the
business of the
kid for life regardless as long as
they're not a complete piece of crap and
like changed on you and we have to I
mean we spend so much time on like okay
he's from a small town what happens when
he hits the big sit like we're just
trying to react us we don't want the
flip listen we don't need we can afford
to not be in the business of getting the
phone call to in the morning so we don't
need to be in that and we're truly not
and the other thing is you get your
heart broken
Wever I already have four seconds in the
business we signed a kid who then fired
us before he went to the league and I
watched it I'm like I'm heartbroken I
love them and so like we want to be very
thoughtful so I think the way we're
gonna beat it but like I think the most
important thing for you from afar and I
haven't done a lot of homework so I
don't want to [ __ ] but squeeze it
while you've got leverage yeah not a lot
of human beings get to be the number one
pick of a team you know it's a real
thing it's really real you know I look
funny and let me tell you something it's
not even like a younger or I respect
that and I don't know and I'm sure he'll
speak for himself like I mean I didn't
understand either like by the way you
don't even understand how I bet you
don't understand how lucky you are to
even be a human being when the math is
400 trillion to 1 how can you you're a
human being it's what you know you know
like I sure you know he can't feel what
it feels like to only be able to throw
57 like the way I can feel it he just
doesn't know what that feels like he did
that and he did that when he was 7 right
like you know the key is empathy you're
right
he doesn't in the same way that all of
us sitting here can't you can't what
you've got you take for granted by the
nature of being a human being it's all
of us around each other that see it
right and so the and so for me it's not
about I have no interest in me you know
I'm surely not here listen I'm
empathetic I love it I'm even more
excited now about the meeting based on
the way it's going but I have no
interest in being like hey listen to me
kid look I [ __ ] me you know that's
that doesn't work the reason so many
kids resonate with me and why I have two
million followers on Instagram is I went
to USC football team and spoke to a
football team like yo for 91 percent of
you is the greatest year of your life
and because it's true it's not cuz I'm
cool or I came in with swag it's cuz
it's true go look at every [ __ ]
person I'm strapped in the first round
it made you look baseball and look at
what's happened a lot of good cuz
there's a lot of [ __ ] talent there
but a lot more bad than you would think
then just cuz its life that's the truth
right so for me it's super compounded
because of the local kid and how big the
money is in New York you can get if you
were the first pick overall for the
Royals off the field money is different
than being a first-round pick for the
Mets in New York as a local kid and all
the advantages you have that's something
you need to debate and it's hard because
it's a counter pull from what no
question you should be focused on just
being a great [ __ ] you like I get it
right like that makes sense that's
that's what should be gone so finding
that right balance I think is super hard
and a challenge but super important
because it becomes I spend a lot of time
with kids that just regret it just
regret regret regret right and it's
sports it's [ __ ] you know I grew up
probably like a lot of people which is
like [ __ ] man I was real sad around 3rd
or 4th grade when I realized it wasn't
gonna happen you know we all grew up
wanting to do what you do but now that
I'm 41 year old man and now that
entrepreneurship is so cool it's even
easier to say [ __ ] man I was a [ __ ]
thank God I wasn't an athlete it's over
when you're 30 like everything that you
know like for a lot of them I think
about running Curtis Martin you know
running backs like it's you know 28
years old running back you're finished
like what Duff's oh you're a kid right
like weed we've lived it right we've
been 28 so I think it's just all those
feelings all those thoughts and I think
it's the balance of like following your
intuition and your gut even when you're
so lucky to have good voices around you
pulling super hard of like doing what
you want to do and believing and that's
real in parallel in the opposite
direction of listening to everything and
filtering it saying not saying no to
anything up front just so you hear it
and then you being the filter too many
kids just say no up front because it's
from their dad it's from somebody else's
like [ __ ] you I'm not
gonna be like you I'm gonna [ __ ] make
all that [ __ ] so many people just don't
even hear it the key the only piece of
advice is hear it and then make your
decisions not for anybody but yourself
not for that man nobody for you cuz
that's that's how you win
that's how there's no resentment that's
how it's real family all the way through
I think people break on both parts they
don't hear every they don't listen to
everything you should listen everything
and they do make decisions for other
people besides themselves and those two
macro vulnerabilities to me or when I
are is really my anchor advise and
squeeze the [ __ ] out of your situation
because it's cuz it's an opportunity
it's an opportunity and you know what's
crazy for me unless I have a terminal
disease
um I should be good he does it I've
become real empathetic to that you know
like I literally sleep every I literally
every night I'm like hope I don't die
hope I'm not sick like I hope nobody I
care about is sick and that's my only
kryptonite
I fight especially now it's over other
than something tragic right to the 7
people I give a [ __ ] about which will
slow me down for a year or mean which is
slow me down completely you got a 1 pack
right that's scary as a [ __ ] man I I
don't envy and I respect the [ __ ] out of
the psychology of that which then
creates even a greater sense of urgency
for me of like hey be thoughtful of how
you want to do this at the same token
putting your face up putting yourself
out there and doing things that's a DNA
thing not everybody is an extrovert not
everybody likes that not everybody wants
to sell out yeah you know like
on stage anything like that so DNA
matters do and when you force kids so I
think it's being thoughtful I my big
thing is reverse engineering dissect the
[ __ ] like for you know if we start a
baseball division he was first dissect
that should like have real talk be like
I don't want you to do [ __ ]
I just want to deliver on what you want
me to do and if you want to get a deal
with you know kit the brand versus this
or if you want to [ __ ] you tell me
you want to do a deal with tape because
you think it's cool great let's reverse
engineer it and you don't if it's just
money and you don't give a [ __ ] about
which bottled water it's just money
which I have empathy for I would do that
with things that I don't care about that
I'm not against you may not drink
alcohol and there's rules know that vote
you mean that drink bottled water and
you don't want to do it because that's
how you roll Mazel Tov you know like
just figuring it out in reverse
engineering and creating avenues he's
he's in position now to make those kind
of deals with the people that become
bait before their babe I think he is I
think if you're a New York again I'm
making way too many assumptions just on
the clothes he's wearing and the vibe
like yes I think there are deals we've
so we've already quickly made a name for
ourselves for getting dollars in places
that people don't think they are whether
off of my equity or just being
strategically smart you know five
minutes okay
Kant gotta go we're getting we're
hurting [ __ ] okay two minutes I would
reverse engineers Queens based Mets spot
like there's a lot of smart things that
could be done so I think the answer is
yes but I don't think adidas is signing
him to a Yeezy deal right so like you
know it's just it's just being realistic
finding interests and finding it's all
about finding opportunities it's finding
startups that are sitting with more
money than they know what to do with and
trying to make the name for themselves
in New York and then compelling them to
understand that this is the guy and then
it's finding the right partners we're
producing content for posts mates and
things of that nature and age you can
walk you through
I know that you got to go to so but like
keep putting pressure on them to think
about it this way but the answer is
whether whether it's to earlier to not
you don't get unless you ask right and
honestly you don't you don't strike me
as a man who needs to wait or you know
and if that's appropriate like you don't
need to wait for your agent you know
like you just do your thing - that's
what's up I appreciate it
that's great I appreciate that can I
have the case I don't - hell yeah I
don't have bend this stuff ultraPro
still around Jesus Christ listen we we
have a lot of conversations about a lot
of things always talk I'm one of the I
didn't I didn't take this meeting just
for kicks and giggles I really wanted to
meet and say hello and say what's up and
like like see where the paths lead feel
free feel free to reach out ad hoc
anytime and I and I will meet that guy
you know feel free to set that up okay
and I wish you success good luck to you
yeah good luck
such a pleasure hope you guys enjoy it
fun fact coffee in Australia is just
[ __ ] good I'll see you soon leave a
comment
please leave me a comment of your
favorite young athlete that's what I
want to see in the YouTube comments
let's make this some of the more
interactive a little more fun thank you
so much for watching the [ __ ] vlog
[Music]